foreign
or I can just shout God there we go good
evening and welcome to the long Now
talks April 2023.
[Applause]
and I you know a special shout out to
you the audience because this is our
first time here in club fugazi what do
you think
and uh and also show hands long now
members wave your hands
and everybody else uh watching remotely
wave your hands and say hello to your
dog
um wonderful to have you here I think
this space works pretty well
um and oh show hands who here has been
to Beach Blanket Babylon
okay that's everybody who's member of
AARP
um
couple of housekeeping details here is
um you you notice they have a bar here
after the talk stay here and continue
your conversation the bar and the food
and everything will be open
and then of course uh for if there's
anyone I this is where I feel a little
bit like the the the flight attendant
doing the seat belt description and
every bit goes yeah yeah I heard it a
million times but in case there's
somebody who's never flown in a long now
talk before you have these uh question
cards and please during the talk if a
question occurs to you
um uh just fill it in and someone will
come past and pick it up and and if you
attach a twenty dollar bill to it uh
Kevin Kelly who uh will be screening
will make sure yours gets done just
kidding don't don't please don't put a
20 odd okay
uh enough for housekeeping it is my
pleasure to introduce Ryan feeling
and
and the job for me I've you know it's
hard to introduce someone you don't know
but it's even harder to introduce
someone you've known for a very long
time and my observation about Ryan is
that she is a Serial Visionary an
entrepreneur who has been working at the
intersection of genomics and biotech and
now conservation but the whole time with
her Focus really clearly on consumers
and the greater public good so now she's
got this wonderful uh well you'll hear
more about what she's up to
um she the official part she's
co-founder and executive director of
revive and restore which if you look at
her bio it would say it's her third
major uh launch of something she'd
previously launched DNA direct and
direct medical knowledge which we're all
about empowering consumers around Health
Care in fact it's not this is not her
third it's like her sixth or her seventh
uh
run at doing really important stuff
um
I should also say in addition to the
formal part she has been a Cornerstone
of the long now Brain Trust since long
now started uh just absolutely essential
to shaping the organization but above
all what I've noticed so my day job is
I'm a long-range forecaster and so I pay
attention to people who are good at
forecasting and Ryan has this absolutely
unerring ability to see emerging
connections way ahead of the crowd way
ahead of the pack and what I've watched
is the first time she'll mention
something new
you know every ago huh that's that's
kind of surprising and interesting then
after a while everybody says oh oh oh in
about a year later oh now I start to get
get it but then eventually that turns
back to surprise because when you
realize what you think you got really
was only part of the story and Ryan was
doing something much deeper and much
more surprising so all I can say is I
invite Ryan up to the stage prepared to
be surprised Ryan
thank you
you know before I begin I first just
want to welcome my friends that are here
and long now members and lots of
familiar faces from over all the years
I'm just curious is anyone here if you
could show a raise your hand here to see
blanket Babylon
okay
so so that's good is anyone here to hear
about conservation raise your hand
okay and how about a show of hands for
those who are interested in biotech
okay well that's a good sign so we're
all on the same page so let me begin
this is a painting by Isabella Kirkland
an incredible artist who's actually in
the audience
[Applause]
its title is back and it depicts 48
species that were all brought back from
the brink of Extinction
this happened just at the end of uh of
the excuse me of the late 1990s and it
was done using traditional tools of
conservation that means these species
were brought into captivity if needed to
create re and be rewilded over time
their habitat was protected they stopped
over hunting these are all the common
tools of conservation
but now as we enter into the 21st
century we have new conservation
challenges we have invasive species like
never before with you know the global
traffic we have novel Wildlife diseases
we have smaller and smaller populations
of endangered species losing genetic
diversity and all of that is compounded
by climate change and everyone in this
room knows that the world is warming and
even the latest projections show that
it's going to get way worse before uh
and we're going to lose a tremendous
loss of biodiversity along the way
now my background actually is in
healthcare I spent several decades in it
and I saw the Human Genome Project when
it was launched
and I knew it was going to be
transformative for health care I could
see the emerging view of personalized
medicine where we could have targeted
Therapeutics and precise Diagnostics and
then we could see this happening with
Precision agriculture as well
and the foundation of that biotechnology
platform really begins with genomic
sequencing high level sequencing and
bioinformatics
and continued with advances in cell
culturing advances in advanced
reproductive techniques and we could see
at the time that genome editing was
coming on the horizon quite fast with
Precision Gene editing
but this platform
had not yet been applied to conservation
and my husband Stuart brand who's a
co-founder of revive and restore and I
were we were both thinking 10 some years
ago what if these tools could be used to
help solve some of the emerging problems
in conservation
and for those of you who know Stuart in
the long now Foundation you won't be
surprised that he opined well you could
probably even use these Technologies to
bring back an extinct species
and the passenger pigeon became one of
our Flagship projects
we started within the long now
Foundation where this idea was incubated
and Stuart and I launched a series of of
meetings with Scientists from around the
world we brought in genome Engineers as
social scientists and ethicists to weigh
the the benefits and the risk of these
kinds of projects
and being became very clear that what we
needed to do is actually start to
socialize these ideas that these tools
were going to actually be used in
conservation
and with that we coined the term
de-extinction and we took it to a Ted
stage we brought 18 scientists that were
actually doing genome editing and
beginnings of de-extinction work all
over the world we brought them to the
stage where they could hash out some of
these issues at National Geographic
now
all along the way where we were creating
this we could see that these tools could
be used all along the way to help
endangered species
and with that we actually named our
organization revive and restore to keep
our eye on the prize which was that it
was really not just about Reviving
individual species but it was really
about ecological restoration
and the first chance we had to work on a
project that would that was really so
profound for organization was with the
black-footed ferret we got a call from
fish and wildlife and we heard the story
of the black-footed ferret
it used to range all across this
landscape
across the Great Plains from Mexico to
Canada and that was until in the 1800s
this land actually became agricultural
fields and the
black-footed ferrets and their primary
source of prey which is the prairie dog
were all literally exterminated and by
1981 they were none
until one small population was found in
matitsi Wyoming
Wyoming Game and Fish brought that small
population into captivity bred them over
time and very successfully have
reintroduced them to over 30 sites back
into their original range
however over 30 years all 10 500 ferrets
have been bred in captivity from just a
Founder gene pool of seven ferrets that
had been wild caught now everybody knows
that inbreeding is not a great thing and
when species
get into smaller and smaller populations
they run the risk of going down the
extinction Vortex when smaller
populations cause greater uh genetic
drift lower fertility counts and even
become more susceptible to Wildlife
diseases increasing their mortality
now when we got the call from Fish and
Wildlife to ask if we could help we
actually
you know the first thing we said was
there any other population that you can
bring in to restore a genetic diversity
because that's the typical tool in
technology bring in a population from
another area and increase fertility
lower the mortality rate increase the
population and becomes more stable
but there was no other population for
the black-footed ferret
so we heard that within the San Diego
frozen Zoo Back 40 years ago somebody
was prescient enough to actually Bank
cell lines from two other individuals
that had been wild caught in 1981 but
had never contributed to the gene pool
with that we did the genomic sequencing
on those two cell lines and we found
that They Carried up to three times more
genetic diversity than any living ferret
so if we could actually clone those
ferrets we could start to build up that
population not by moving animals but by
moving genes
in by partnering with the San Diego Zoo
and our partner viogen uh as a cloning
company and with U.S fish and wildlife
under their permit
in 2020 we cloned Elizabeth Anne she's
the first
she's the first endangered species in
America to ever be cloned
now this is an amazing success story and
and it was a first for conservation to
actually use these Technologies in this
way but to me what's actually almost
more amazing is the fact that scientists
back in 1980s were present enough to
start to think about cryopreservation
now cloning didn't exist then at all
they didn't know what they were going to
do with these cells and that got us
thinking what else has been ever cryo
preserved
it turns out that less than 14 percent
of U.S endangered species have any form
of cryopreservation that includes uh
plants and animals out of the 1500
that's an alarming low number and it's a
particularly alarming low number when
you realize the rate of Extinction loss
just in the last hundred years and the
trend keeps going up
so with that we started talking with
officials at Fisher Wildlife service and
we suggested to them that if we could
figure out why this isn't happening that
we could actually help create protocols
and a and actually a road map to help
ensure that every species
that is endangered in the U.S and by the
way they are all on recovery plans for
these animals and the Fish and Wildlife
service has a responsibility to actually
get them back off the list
we've said why don't they just include
in that whole process taking a cell
culture and ensuring that they that
species has a reference genome that can
be open access and used by researchers
all over the world
so with this idea we're trying to
actually Bank species for the present to
help make better management decisions
based on their DNA but the truth is
they're really going to be put in the
bank to also help future generations
with unknown technologies that are
Unthinkable today but could be
transformative in the future
and here's our partner Seth Willey this
is actually the same guy who called us
to ask could we help him with the
black-footed ferret Ten Years Later Seth
is a major partner in this whole
initiative
you know we're responsible in the
southwest region there's about 200
threatened endangered species Nationwide
responsible for about 1500 threat and
endangered species and it got me
wondering you know are we doing our part
to set up future Generations the same
way somebody set up Blackford Affair for
that success 30 years before by
biobanking by cryogenically preserving
that specimen that sample
and the answer we came to was
Hit or Miss I mean we're doing it in
Little Bits here and there you know in
conservation if one of the first
premises is save what you have
this is one tool that gives us that
option to save what we have not for
academic purposes but for recovery for
genetic rescue and push species back to
the point of being biologically viable
in this game in conservation dangerous
species recovery we're entrusted to
protect some of the nation's most
valuable and unique biological resources
that conservation Legacy is entrusted to
us and we're responsible for trying to
arrest a species decline to manage
threats and to bring species back from
the brink
genetic diversity took millions of years
to evolve and
you know we're losing it on our watch
but it's not too late right there's
still great opportunity for those
Critters and for many others it's our
responsibility to try to do what we can
to say what's there today
so that's what we're doing we've started
this pilot with our first species that's
the Mexican wolf it is native to New
Mexico and Arizona there are only 200
left in the wild today
and on a routine vet check last month
the fueled biologist team
working with revive and restore
where we sent them a protocol and we
sent them a tissue collection kit
actually was able to sample that Mexican
wolf
send off the sample to our culturing
partner with viogen and it's now on its
way for sequencing and we'll be going
for long-term storage at a federal
facility so one down we've got another
1500 to do
so you know we've talked about
cryopreservation with mammals and we
started there because really to be quite
honestly the easiest to do the
technology is well known how to sell
culture but for many organisms it's
incredibly hard
and we're working on some Innovative
research to actually try to figure out a
solution to that but probably nothing is
more important right now than working
with coral there are over 800 species of
reef building corals and coral reefs
plays such an incredible role in
ecosystem they support not only Marine
fishes marine organisms and fish mammals
they also provide coral reefs provide
incredible support to humans they
protect our Shores and they create the
livelihood for over a billion people
and we're losing coral reefs in an
alarming rate projections Say by 2050 we
may lose 90 percent of the coral reach
from pleaching now bleaching is not
always 100 extinction because if Coral
have a chance to rebound the next year
with cooler Waters and less
acidification and and no fishing
trawling on them and everything else if
they don't have repeated insults they
can actually come back
and so we need to capture that
biodiversity before it's really gone so
that we can actually help bring those
reefs back to fruition and we're working
right now with a project with Mary
hagerdorn a leading scientist at the
Smithsonian let's hear from Mary
I've been working on the
cryopreservation of marine species since
1993 and I realized it was going to be
important because you could tell the
oceans were going to be in trouble from
Gun Exchange initially when I started I
was really just trying to work out the
science of how we do this but then it
became very clear that things were
changing very rapidly and climate change
and bleaching events were happening and
you know I became very worried that we
needed to get the science done quickly
I work on the conservation of coral and
I use human fertility techniques to do
this basically we are crowd preserving
or freezing however we want to think of
it um gametes the sperm and the larvae
of coral as well as small fragments of
coral and the reason we are interested
in fusing cryop preservation is that it
allows us to stop time really we can
freeze coral and keep them for a day in
our bank or 10 years or 100 years or a
thousand years so it gives us the
ability to use this material today or
save it for many many years in the
future to potentially reseed the ocean
one of the major outcomes of our roses
is scalability we want to be able to cry
or preserve Coral easily and cheaply so
that every professional that wants to
around the world can form their own
cryopreserve Banks of coral and thus
speed up the process of secure during
the biodiversity and genetic diversity
of coral My Hope for what we're doing is
that these tools these these frozen
assets that we're developing with
product preservation can be used to help
for restoration today but also can be
used to help reseed the oceans in the
future
so Mary's project is one of eight that
revive and restore is funding right now
we call it the advanced Coral tool kit
and we have researchers working at
understanding the underlying genetics
that allow some reefs to be resilient
and and continue in in the warming
Waters some that may even show signs of
resilience to disease and coral disease
is wiping out corals all the way from
Florida right now down into the
Caribbean with what's called Coral Stony
lost disease
so as these scientists are working
they're developing the ability to create
Coral stem cells that could be used to
repopulate Reeves as well as new
techniques using proteomics and other
parts of uh of research to figure out
how to combine these tools so that we
can actually make a big difference when
we can take it make it effort at
restoration
now we've talked about coral we've
talked about cryopreservation for a bit
here but I want to make it really clear
that one of the most simple and and
which should be a ubiquitous tool for
conservation is genomic sequencing that
foundational level for everything
and as sequencing costs have plummeted
over the years this is a tool that I
just wish more conservationists could
actually access
um and we're doing our effort to try to
make it more ubiquitous
we have two projects I want to talk
about that I think are really exciting
just in the way that they're using that
genetic insight to make better
management decisions around these
endangered species and the first one
takes us uh to Kenya with an Irishman
named Andy Tai who's been doing some
incredible work
arabico is the largest remaining
remnants of coastal forest in all of
East Africa and it has a high degree of
endemic species and there's a population
of elephants that are currently living
in this Forest which in the past would
have been connected to other populations
of audience between those in Sabo and
for the north side but now they're
surrounded by an electric fence because
it's such a dense environment it's been
very difficult to actually counter many
albums are in there and it's very
difficult to manage
if you don't know how many exist
when this project is kind of pushing new
boundaries is that this this will be the
first time a snip array has been
developed for Savannah elephants Snips
are single nucleotides polymorphisms
it's basically one base pair in the
genome where individuals differ and when
you amalgamate all those differences
across an individual's genome that
pattern of steps is unique to the
individual but using this approach we
can see how many individuals are in the
forest and the way that we're doing that
is non-invasively using Scott
in arabico we have a unique situation
where in the dry season all of the
elephants in the forest are forced to
visit one wall wrinkle and what this
means is that we can get a snapshot
every album in the forest as it comes to
drink it will relieve itself and leave
us a sample and as we sample over the
course of two or three weeks we should
in theory cover the entire population
knowing this wallet stories and kind of
will have a clear idea pressures that
are on the forest and if the number is
quite High it will indicate to Wildlife
authorities or perhaps some elephants
should be translocated or a wildlife
Corridor should be put in in a way
almost like a release file with a unique
part of our project is that we are
helping to develop a local lab in Kenya
and by having it based in country
it means that these sorts of projects
could be happening with much higher
frequency and are reliant on people like
me flying in sales editing stuff like
this
ideally in the future human civilization
will have space for nature but at the
moment it's a fight so areas like Arabic
or sukoke
need to be protected in their entirety
which includes the elephants and all the
Aromas are in there so that in the
future when we have
space and and tolerance to be able to
spread out uh this is true of all wild
places around the world
what I love about that project is
elephants are absolutely invisible from
the sky and you know elephants don't
like drones either but even if you could
you could not see them as much from the
air so they really don't know
the size of the population and they
don't know the level of inbreeding that
could be happening in a closed
population so by looking at that
individual fingerprint of those animals
they not only know their genetic
diversity but they will begin to even
understand what plants they're eating
and how they might even create a
migratory path for them a wildlife
Corridor that actually would be
um of the of the right plants for the
elephants
Now using genomic insight has a a very
different take in a very interesting
situation close to our home here in
California
and we're going to go to our California
kelp forest this is a healthy kelp
forest and this is the way it used to be
from Baja California to Alaska Rich
diverse ecosystem once again creating
like a coral reef creating the habitat
for millions of organisms and nurturing
mammals along the way like the sea otter
that wraps itself up in kelp when it
goes to sleep to help keep sharks at Bay
now what creates this healthy ecosystem
is the sea star there are eight
different species of sea stars all up
along the coast where they should be and
they got hit very hard by an unknown
invasive pathogen
and it's called sea star wasting disease
and it absolutely disintegrates these
sea stars
now
that billions of sea stars used to be
here until 2013.
and what is replacing them
is all purple sea urchins now the sea
urchins
and the sea stars once lived uh in
balance
but once they got removed
it just became urchin barons
it's been it's been identified that
we've lost 95 percent of our kelp all
along this West Coast it's a horrific
number these are the Bold kelp the ones
that should be like a forest
and these urchin Barons
um are terrifying particularly because
they can last for up to 50 years they
just go dormant they don't have anything
to eat they get just get
you know
uh they're you know they're not good for
anything
and even though we think of urchin for
those of us who eat sushi and things
like that we think of uni and oh my gosh
that could should be a great resource
why don't we just Harvest them there is
a company that's trying to do that but
the truth is there's they're so starved
in this environment right now that the
only way to commercialize them is to put
them in captive breeding and feed them
and then try to sell them to the
Japanese Market it's a crazy horrible
situation and right now there's a lot of
different ideas of how to remove these
uh urchins there's an urchin Baron that
can be seen that is 400 miles long off
our Coast from Marin County to the
Oregon border
so right now there are commercial divers
that are vacuuming them up there are
volunteers are scuba diving and picking
them up there's robots that are being
deployed there's lots of Technology but
there's one technology when it was
proposed to us for research that we
thought biotech might have a solution
and I'm going to let Mike Dawson tell
that story
the question for us was is there a way
to reintroduce the sunflower sea star to
California Oregon Washington and to help
those populations that are reintroduced
be more resilient to Future change right
whether that's changes in ocean
temperature ocean acidification or other
breaks of wasting disease
and so the way we approach this
essentially with try to work out what
diversity was remaining or what
diversity is survived that's after the
wasting disease and having identified
Those portions of the genome we're
developing the weight so rapidly assess
the diversity of genomes
to identify which animals should have a
tendency to be resilient wasting disease
we're now collaborating with the team in
Washington to use information that we
have by the genomics in a breeding
program to restore populations in the
wild
with an age Conservancy we're now
actually collaborating to try to do that
part of it the next part of that project
will be to take the tools that we're
developing with the robot and restore
into that actually more you know real
applied setting that has been for lunch
and go could become more willing to try
Technical Solutions to conservation
problems in part because we've just
learned a huge map more about Marine
systems in the last several decades you
know over that same period of time two
to three decades we and the general
population become much much more aware
about how severe the current threats
actually are so the need for action
and so the idea is that by restoring
population of sea stars we would also be
able to help build the resilience forest
ecosystems
so I think is a great example of
biotechnology being an interesting part
of the solution but let's be clear it's
not going to be the magic fix it's going
to take all kinds of innovation and
Technology from robots to Aerial surveys
to you know divers actually removing
them in great quantities but it's the
combination it's the integration of
these Technologies it is starting to
happen that is exactly why we started
this organization
let's talk about Birds now
one in eight species of birds are
threatened with globally with Extinction
it's an alarming number half of them are
in Decline
in Hawaii alone Hawaii has lost 75
percent of their endemic species some of
that is due to climate change habitat
loss but it's also due to avian disease
we've been trying to figure out how to
use some of the technologies that we're
using in mammals as in cloning to
actually influence and help this solve
some of these challenges with birds
but the problem with the bird is it has
a very unique reproductive system
the embryo is tucked inside
the egg
and the egg is a huge barrier
mammals with uteruses are actually easy
to manipulate it turns out and what it's
going to take to change and actually
develop Advanced reproductive
Technologies for Birds is different it's
called germline transfer and it's
actually been done successfully in the
poultry industry
with with chickens and what we're trying
to do is learn from that technology and
to apply it for endangered birds
we've just announced a program called
biotechnology for bird conservation and
we have eight International Teams
working on this exact problem they're
taking different paths they're some of
them are incredibly synergistic and some
of them will be sequential but all of
them are working together to actually
solve this challenge
the way it would be done is you would
take those primordial germ cells from
the endangered bird and you would
transfect them into a domestic surrogate
in this illustration into both sexes of
the chicken and The Offspring would
actually be the wild bird just like we
did with the ferret we used a domestic
ferret to have a wild black-footed
ferret
if we could do that you could actually
repopulate some of these small limited
endangered populations because those
common birds could actually have
multiple chicks and multiple times a
year whereas the endangered birds if
they're lucky they get two or three
chicks a year maybe one or two survive
and you can't rebuild the population
I'm going to introduce Eric Jarvis one
of our scientists that we're working
with at Rockefeller University
my main line of research is
understanding brain mechanisms of vocal
learning the ability to imitate sounds
like we do for speech and there are only
a few species that have this ability
besides us humans like sombers and
parrots and whales and as I started to
get involved in comparing the brains and
genomes of multiple species I started to
realize that a number of them I wanted
to study are critically endangered and
that got me more involved also in
conservation because I feel like it's a
moral duty for us scientists to get
involved maintaining bird cells The Germ
cells that is for whatever reason is
harder to do than the equivalent cells
for males there's something about bird
cells that they need to be inside the
egg in order to develop properly than in
a culture dish my lab and many other
labs are trying to figure out what is
the magic sauce that these bird cells
need that we've already figured out for
mammals but not for Birds yet and when
you think once they figured out for
Birds it's going to be the same for
reptile because the Earth are basically
reptiles and they have the same egg
laying kind of system
a lot of folks think that conservation
should be only about trying to put
fences up to save species from
population Decline and not really get
into the biology of you know diseases of
these animals or the genetics and so
forth I often have to explain to
conservation-minded folks that putting
up fences is not enough what small
population size pumps the prevalence for
more susceptibility to disease human
population growth is going to continue
to grow we must find Martin means to
live in coexistence with species without
causing their extermination and so
for my efforts in conservation
undoing them not only because I'm
fascinated by the science but also
because I feel like it's necessary it's
necessary for our survival
and the truth is
if Eric Jarvis and the other scientists
that we're working with are actually
successful someday we might even have
back the passenger pigeon
and when we do there could well be
another iconic species that was lost and
that's the American chestnut tree and
it's coming back
these are American chestnuts they used
to rain down from these enormous trees
all across the Eastern Forest
I hope you're seeing those little people
under that huge tree there were billions
of these trees all across this range
by the 1850s a blight came in from the
Landscaping trade
that absolutely decimated these trees it
was called chestnut tree blight and all
that's left all across that range is
just the ghost of those roots
sometimes they sprout up but they never
really come to any significant fruition
the good part of the story
is that for the last 30 years there have
been scientists at State University of
New York that have been trying to figure
out how they can create a chestnut tree
that is blight resistance and they've
succeeded
um it's really incredible what they've
done and they've done it with one trans
Gene from wheat
by creating and transfecting this gene
into wheat they've made a blight
resistant chest in a tree
now his team has had to go through
incredible hurdles to bring this tree
through the regulatory path because it
is the first genetically engineered wild
species
they've been planting these trees in
experimental plots The Regulators have
made them go through every single
experiment to demonstrate that they
carry no safety risk because at the end
of the day those chestnuts might be
eaten by people and animals alike
this is Bill Powell he's the scientist
who has pushed this forward and he's
really been a model for revive and
restore and the part that I particularly
love about his story and and why we
didn't have to fund them all we had to
do was just advocate for the tree is
because he actually was transparent
about the research that he was doing
from the beginning
he mobilized a whole American chestnut
tree Foundation movement and with that
support they've been able to go through
that regulatory process and I believe
this year is the year that these trees
will be commercially available now
they're going to Smart they're going to
start with small introduction of the
trees for sale ideally they'll begin
with in biological reserves in Botanical
Gardens and other areas just to get them
really established back in their range
but they are coming to every backyard
Gardener in their original historic
range soon
now revive and restore has been involved
over the last 10 years on 54 projects
and we've been funding projects in 16
Nations
and those projects are focused on 70
wild species
but wild species don't live in a vacuum
they require healthy ecosystems and
those ecosystems
include people their culture and their
values
now we were really excited when we heard
that there was a project called one
people one Reef operating in the middle
of the Western Pacific in Micronesia and
what excited us about this project was
the fact that it was trying to combine
traditional law traditional knowledge
with modern science with indigenous
people
let's hear from Magoo Mall
where we're from the Eton of eulipi it's
part of the Yap state in the chain of
what we call the outer islands and it's
basically about a stretch of 99 Islands
in Micronesia
we're very subsistence Community we
depend so much on maybe 90 on our
resources our local resources so we
still grow our own food with very little
import
I think like many many people many many
Coastline communities we are facing
climate change and that's no surprise to
everybody but definitely not for us we
used to be able to predict certain birds
and certain fish migrate associated with
these weather patterns and those
Associated stars that we call the the
traditional markers now these patterns
have changed quite a bit and we can't
depend so much on on traditional
knowledge because it's changed and so I
think that acceptance of that and that
willingness to to seek further or new
information kind of started earlier on
we need to seek more information because
it's moving much faster than we ever
know so it takes science it takes you
know genomics and and DNA that is now
collected to the way the more accurate
counts of assessing The Reef health and
the fish count it takes that kind of
Science and knowledge to be able to help
us make a decision on management
we've seen positive changes in combining
these wisdoms of the West and and
traditional knowledge and coming up with
creative ways to adapt to the first
decline in in some areas I think that
the responsibility now in my mind is to
spread this through the region on low
lines English like us to join the
efforts and see from the 10 years of
data of how we can and we will be able
to to fight some of these fast-changing
decline in our reefs and resources
now the challenges that magul and his
people are facing may seem very remote
to everybody sitting in this room
but I suspect that most of you don't
realize that we actually do impact
endangered species in ways that you may
not even think of it
this is a blue bottle
it's actually called blue blood
and probably everyone in this room has
benefited from this substance
it's harvested every year from horseshoe
crabs
four hundred thousand crabs a year are
harvested on the East Coast
they're impaled in these factories where
one third of their blood is drained
and the reason that you've benefited
from this is because of that blue
protein
it is used for every drug injectable
drug or vaccine that you've ever had or
anyone you know to make them safe safe
from the impurities in the manufacturing
process that could come in from bacteria
in the water
that Lal substance is referred to is the
gold standard for drug manufacturing
today and it's used with not only drugs
and vaccines with every implanted device
and it's used even in veterinary
medicine
but here is where the horseshoe crab
lives
this species comes in
once a year on the high tides of manjim
to spawn and it spawns in the thousands
of eggs every year
and it provides not only for the
proliferation of its species but also is
sustenance for wild birds and a whole
ecosystem
and these wild birds in particular this
is the Red Knot they migrate all the way
from the tip of South America all the
way to the Arctic Circle and they make
one pit stop in Delaware Bay to refuel
on the eggs of the horseshoe crab now
these species are being listed they're
endangered they're not making it to the
Arctic Circle and when they're making it
to the Arctic Circle those that do are
so thin and underfed that they usually
are not reading
this is a multi-continent ecological
problem and it's something that is done
for the welfare of humanity
that's why it's so linked to everything
that we do
but it doesn't have to be that way
and that's where synthetic biology comes
in
scientists back in 1995 at the
University of Singapore Dr Ling and Dr
Ho actually identified that unique
protein in the horseshoe crab that they
make the Lal
substance from and that unique protein
was synthesized and has been created
what was called the recombinant factor C
that RFC has languished on the market
because of corporate greed because
there's so much money in the blood of
the horseshoe crab
and it's also because of bureaucratic
inertia and Regulatory inertia
we don't have any Financial arrangement
in this we're not a supporter one way or
another of the pharmaceutical industry
but to be really clear we've been
advocating for the pharmaceutical
companies to do something to adopt the
synthetic alternative to force the
regulatory authorities to do something
we and other conservation groups have
organized a coalition and we've sent
letters Ad nauseam but one really bold
scientist from Eli Lilly has changed the
whole dynamic
before I go to Jay I should say a little
bit about how endotoxin which is what
this testing of impurities uh in the
history about it it used to be in 1942
that drug manufacturers used rabbits to
test for any kind of impurity
by 1965 they learned about the uh the
horseshoe crab blood with this unique
property for early detection and within
12 years that got approved by regulators
and it became the gold standard
today
recombinant factor C has been on the
market for close to 30 years and the
only way a drug manufacturer can use it
is by jumping through an incredible
amount of hurdles to demonstrate
that added safety and one bold company
with one bold scientist has changed that
up and that's Jay Bolden
I I'm a murderer so I have a unique
perspective in that I can see the impact
of the horseshoe crab not only because
of the horseshoe crab itself but the the
species that rely on it including birds
and turtles and sport fish and all you
know anything that's in the ecosystem
that it's impacted and so we were aware
at Lily that there was an alternative to
the to the Lal test reagent we generated
the data but it took a lot of alignment
internally and then externally we had to
convince the FDA and other health
authorities around the world but we did
that with our data and we convinced them
we drew a line in the sand of 2016 and
we said that all new drugs that are
manufactured at the lake
we would apply the common factor C to
them and so our first product was
approved in 2018 and that was a
milestone because that was at first in
Industry approval of any medicine using
RFC pro-release and then we've
subsequently had six additional products
approvals since then including our three
covid-19 antibodies our goal when we set
out was to convert all eight of our
manufacturing quality control Labs at
the time to RFC and we've done that and
it's been Industries following we have
we have our peers sanofi and Pfizer and
roshanentec have all come out and made
statements similar to what we've done
which is that we'll converter water
testing and all of our new product
testing so there's definitely a momentum
towards more sustainable indoor products
and testing
we look forward to progress everywhere
that will make it easier for all
companies who have to test for endotoxin
to be able to do some sustainable
alternative to Lal
[Applause]
one footnote on that
America truly is lagging behind on this
adoption Europe Japan Korea have all
adopted the standards to approve RFC in
testing it's really our country that is
the problem
the horseshoe crab has been around for
445 million years it's seen it basically
it looks exactly the same as it did as a
living as a fossil now we can tell that
it hasn't changed very much it's
survived five mass extinctions
from volcanic eruptions climate change
asteroids and it's not until the last
100 years that humans have threatened it
with Extinction
I believe that when humans
cause the problem we have a
responsibility to create Solutions
if we look back Ten Thousand Years the
world was very different
planet
there was much more biodiversity more
kinds of creatures and much greater
amount of biodiversity many more
animals and plants and other organisms
but because of our human presence we
have actually closed out so many of
those opportunities to let those species
thrive
we're at a point in time where I think
that by combining both conventional
approaches to conservation along with
new technologies and biotechnology that
we can actually Envision a much richer
more bioaduct bio-abundant future
truth is it takes time to make changes
happen in conservation
the conservationists that we work with
in some cases they have to work at the
pace of nature
but the truth is they all live in the
long now
and we're all looking to have to see how
we can build a better future
thank you
[Applause]
ah
have a seat yeah
I've got about three hours of questions
here
oh boy I get to see everybody
oh yes so we can sort of hardly kind of
see you all
um uh but they're there trust me
I a question occurred to me as you were
talking about the adorable horseshoe
crabs
um and we've talked about terms at long
now before
is living fossil a wrong term
well it's interesting I guess I use it
because
it looks exactly like the fossil and so
it seems like a living fossil but you
know you can correct me no but I'm just
I'm just it had not occurred to me you
said if fossils sort of evokes something
that's like well you know long gone it's
like a guest who's been too long at a
cocktail party
um
I mean Stuart Stewart will put you to
work on thinking about this what's a
better term is you know something about
biological Elders or the like but I
better get to my job is to ask questions
of other people and not ask my own so
I'll save that for later
um
and Kevin's done a wonderful job on the
well in fact I'm going to ask Uh Kevin
quellick Kevin Kelly question yeah
um what a surprise a Kevin Kelly
question Kevin always has great so every
time we do this I just always determine
I'm never going to ask a Kevin question
but he asked such good questions okay go
ahead what kind and range of money would
be needed to run a national biobank with
samples of all the endangered species
and such a damn good question Kevin and
it's one that I don't have an answer for
um but I know it'll take an act of
Congress to get federal dollars to do it
and we should get that through
Congressional dollars
um I am talking to people at the
national offices about this of what it
would take so I'll tell you the federal
storage facilities are there the
databasing infrastructure is more or
less there
the challenge of getting field biologist
to actually add this extra step in their
process
it's not a big deal they actually like
doing it they understand the value and
in many cases it's a one-off I mean they
may get one at a time
um the the cell culturing with mammals
not a big deal so you know probably a
million going into new research on cell
culturing is definitely a number that is
going to have to happen and that could
be for birds as well as other species
but I think the biggest challenge is
actually getting the mandate to do it
and my goal is to actually get it
written into these recovery plans which
the biologists have to do as part of
their work it's you know this is their
job in the U.S is to protect these
endangered species and this is our
American Legacy if we do it right
so you lost me at act of Congress
no no I mean it's I mean I I wouldn't
seriously propose that genetic
engineering could solve our problem of
members of Congress but
um no no is the Bible I know but no I'm
I'm going somewhere with this
you you give the example of where you've
worked with other organizations to help
accelerate acceptance and to overcome
things that just seemed well
what are in the political realm what are
things that need to be done maybe not by
revive and restore but you said
conservation takes time
and that's correct
um what would speed it up I'm not so
sure that it needs to speed up in some
ways you know this is this is working at
the pace of nature
um there's plenty of bureaucracy that
I'd like to to speed up and
um but but I think that
it's actually been a kind of a healthy
thing you know when Stuart and I started
this we wanted to socialize these ideas
to have a public dialogue about it
and um I think I think that's been good
for the culture people need to to
actually realize how important these
Technologies can be and to integrate
them
a very long nourish answer
um too closely related questions here
um and I'm gonna start with Jenny uh and
then I'll ask the second one which is
anonymous
which conservation organizations in
revive and restore
or which conservation which is revive
and restore currently partnering with
and or which would you seek to partner
with in the future and part two of that
is how do you find and choose your
projects and partners
and how do you support them what are the
ways you support them
so
um probably the the biggest bang for our
buck of all of those projects is just
enabling genomic sequencing some of
those projects we may fund fifty
thousand dollar grants some of them 250
000 a few up to a million over three
years kind of thing but it's really
getting these foundational tools into
their hands and that's something that is
just going to get cheaper to do and
ultimately you won't need revive and
restore to do that because they'll be
able as a conservation organization or
land stewards to be able to just make
that happen on their own but for now
we're kind of a Gateway for a lot of
these organizations at that front the
bigger projects like the engineering you
know really thinking about how to
advance reproduction for Birds those are
much bigger projects now back to the
question of conservation organizations
when we think about how we're making a
difference our goal isn't to
um
our goal isn't just to
try these ideas move the science forward
it's actually to integrate it into a
functioning ecosystem and we are never
going to be in a position to do that we
need the nature conservancies of the
world to take those genetically uh
resilient sea stars captive breed them
and reintroduce them to the wild that's
a huge progress process that has to
happen by other organizations not us so
we're the kind of bleeding edge try it
de-risk ideas organization enable people
to start to use these tools and hope
that they
get translated out to you know the big
ngos
so when you're
starting a relationship
you've been around for 10 years now
what does the Arc of the beginning of
the relationship how do they typically
happen and how does it evolve and when
does it take off well we've done a
really fun thing that we didn't know if
it would work very well but we call the
um we started a program three years ago
called wild genomes and we asked for
people to apply for research money to do
sequencing on endangered or threatened
species but we put a very important uh
requirement in it that it had to be
actionable that it couldn't be just
purely academic it had to be something
information that once they gleaned from
The genome that they could apply in a
way that it could actually help protect
the species and so you know we've had
way more proposals than we could ever
fund so we're looking for funding
Partners now as we build out that
program and so right now we have a uh we
just finished an open call around kelp
ecosystems and we did that in
partnership with the Morris animal
foundation and
um and the web Family Foundation and so
they're kind of co-partners in it and we
actually have joint calls and we have
advisory boards that select the projects
um uh in a really good healthy
functioning partnership so I hope we can
do more of that with funders
what about citizens at large
citizen science fit in yeah you know
there's wonderful citizen science going
on and they are
um in
incredible new Force I think on on the
horizon
um we know one of the one of the
organizations I think it's called
Adventure scientists that is doing cool
things but
um and we're not the scientists so we're
letting the way that we hear about some
of these projects or scientists are
coming to us who are really doing the
work
um and we fund them to do the work and
in a case of like Andy Tai in Dublin
we're actually helping him fund that
capacity to create those labs on site in
Kenya and I love that part of it
um other projects we envision on our own
with the black-footed ferret uh the
person who came to us was U.S fish and
wildlife they didn't really have the
solution we had to come up with it and
then we built the team around it and
we're continuing to do that with the
with the work on the birds by the way I
should credit Gene Trombley was one to
ask that question thank you Gene and a
question for the audience who here has a
uh uh it has a garage genome sequencing
lab
Andrew do you want to raise your hand
there's at least one in this room did I
see another hand show up
good and and has anybody uh managed to
buy I want you to know that uh somebody
in the audience happened to know this
Giacomo from one people one reef and I
forget the statistic he gave me but he
just completed at least two fish genomes
out on a reef uh in the outer Islands uh
in like a clinical facility or something
like it was like a crazy crazy situation
and he did it
yeah well I mean so it's happening
what's the going rate for thermocyclers
on eBay these days
seriously Andrew what 200 bucks
about 200 bucks I mean you how much
would it cost to sorry to put you on
spot what would it cost to build a lab
in the garage
this is great so everybody who has a
teenage male uh who's not quite properly
socialized if you're a grandparent this
is how you terrify the parents is you
you buy them a genome kit to run in the
garage what could possibly go wrong
speaking of which we have a question
about unintended consequences I love
that
so first of all
um I I really like to flip that question
and say what about the intended concept
you want me to ask the question oh well
go ahead
just say it
this is from uh uh Anonymous is very
prolific in this audience
um quote restore uh to which benchmark
point do you restore to how do you
decide what the state is now that
doesn't have anything to do with an okay
well never mind
can we talk about about intended
consequences because in the last 10
years I always get the question of you
know we don't know about the unknown
unknowns and yeah that's right we don't
but we got to flip that question and say
what about the benefits of trying things
I mean when I first started talking to
choral biologists and this was really
early on and we could see what was going
on with global warming
almost everyone I talked to said it is
so desperate Ryan I mean they were like
going through PTSD diving they said
it's so radical we don't dare do
anything
to risk the unintended consequences of
meddling with the reefs and that is
really flipped in the last five years
Mary hagerdorn and all the scientists
that we're funding they're actually
saying we have to intervene we may not
have to genetically engineer we may take
those corals that are doing well on one
part of a reef and we may translate into
another part where they could still do
better or we could you know help with
breeding and and
repopulating but some of them are
actually open to where the technology
will take them in order to save the
reefs so I think it's the risk benefit
equation that has to be played out and
um it just depends on people's tolerance
and I've seen that tolerance shift
um where's Isabella no Kirkland yeah so
Isabella
so
who was familiar with Isabella's art
before this evening Joy hands oh yeah
the rest of you after this evening is
over do not walk run to your nearest web
browser these are the most exquisitely
beautiful paintings and they're just
chock full of information so Isabella
had a rather plaintive one-word question
oh
plants question mark question mark are
we engaged in some some species
chauvinism here yeah actually we are
easy you really put me on the spot there
well we don't have a specific project on
Plants except the Joshua Tree
the Joshua Tree which pardon
it will but the chestnut is not
technically our project I just am a huge
advocate for it and as I said it's been
a model for for us for all these years
but the Joshua tree is a project that
we've been funding again funding
starting with the genomic sequencing to
understand how this tree can actually
adapt with climate change it is not
going to make it where it is for sure
but what they do know is that some of
these trees are showing some resilience
to warming uh temperatures and so they
are doing the experimentation to see if
they could actually move those trees to
another location based on that
resilience
um and and certainly Izzy to answer your
question that more than any species
that's been crowd preserved have been
plants either in seed banks or in cryo
facilities so that's kind of the easier
one to tackle but
um you know the chestnut tree is a model
for so many trees that are near and dear
to us here in California with sudden Oak
death with Hawaii
uh you know there there's no end of
pathogens affecting these beautiful 100
200 year old trees and more and they're
invasive pathogens they don't belong in
the environment this is not kind
Evolution happening
forget climate change I was just
thinking how do you save the Joshua
trees from all the hipsters well there's
that even into the desert but I know I
read about the Joshua tree and I think
oh God what can biotech do with all the
all their problems
um
question for the audience so who here uh
who here took organic chemistry in
college
oh wow right and so forget you we're
gonna ignore uh everybody else who here
feels just like I mean you know that
this is important otherwise you wouldn't
be here but genetics genomics and it all
reminds you of those unpleasant College
experiences and you're just a little
intimidated by it is there anybody in
the room like that
no nobody's raising their hands
this is such a cool audience okay well
never mind I was going to ask you to
talk a little bit about you know good
Let's ignore that but I'm going to ask
you a question I didn't take those
classes you know I'm just an
entrepreneur and
um she's also not good at pool but she
likes to play for money
but are we out of course I have a
question no I have a question for you
um
everybody leaves this tonight and they
talk to their friends about what's going
on
what's an easy way to talk about the
science to make it not seem forbidding
gosh I thought I did that
well nobody raised their hand so clearly
work
okay so Kev I give up Kevin has a
question
what what is a tool or technology that
seems almost possible that would make
your mission easier
stem cell technology I have a really
good answer for that one so one of the
things that I'm learning and again this
is kind of drafting behind human
medicine
is that stem cell technology is changing
everything in human medicine I mean you
know what did I just read the other day
that stem cells were being used you know
these are cells that are taken from your
own body that are then implanted to
reduce inflammation or to you know to
help with Parkinson's all these
different applications
but understanding how to develop those
stem cells has been incredibly hard
now they've never been used for
conservation not really and so because
of that
um revive and restore is going to host
this fall a workshop and I've invited
now probably 20 different scientists
that are doing stem cell research in all
different fields from veterinary
medicine stem cells are big with horses
I'm an equestrian I can tell you many
high performance horses get stem cell
injections
they do these things first with animals
and they do it with prized cattle and
prized horses
um and then they work it down to humans
I want to work it the other way and work
it for wildlife
so we're going to gather these
scientists together and we're going to
do a format that I've used in other
workshops which is really interesting
um we've done it now I think four
different times on different topics and
the secret to the success of this and it
really has been a success is we get you
know 30 40 different people from very
different disciplines
to all work over three days night and
day in a retreat facility and we give
them three different challenges that
they all buy into they elect and opt in
to different work groups and at the end
of the three days they're supposed to
identify the problem identify the
solution develop a road map on how to
get there and develop what they think
could be the translational Partners to
make it happen and the funders and then
I have a mock group of funders who are
present on the third day of the workshop
and I can tell you the night before
these teams stay up half the night
trying to get their decks together and
they'd pitch it as if for real
and what has happened on numerous of
these Workshops the funders stepped up
and incredible research has moved
forward one in particular on Gene drives
for rodents on Islands it was incubated
at one of our workshops and so I want to
do that with stem cells because no one's
paying attention to it and it's the
secret ingredient that will allow all of
these different projects to move forward
for engineering
wow
[Applause]
does this thing have a name
well it doesn't have a good name it's
called the stem cell workshop for
wildlife
how about bio charrette
oh I'm going to work on that yeah yeah
no I need a better name taking that
notion of this artist charette but it's
really great yesterday I was on the
phone at six o'clock with Singapore
Singapore is big on stem cell research
and I've got three institutions
um already lined up to participate
I just need the funders
funders in the audience
reach up director
um doc has a question is it possible you
you answered this partly in your talk
but I I think they're saying can you
push it further Dobb says is it possible
to use Gene editing to create artificial
genetic diversity for threatened
populations
I don't think I really understand that
artificial yeah say it again
um or Dove are you
stand up and shout
um
yeah I think I I think I can answer that
question that I don't know that I would
use it artificial but one idea early on
was
um the black-footed ferrets are actually
very susceptible to plague that's a
whole other problem I don't want to
depress you with and it's ubiquitous
across the Great Plains but some species
are resilient to plague and so looking
at the domestic ferret which is
resistant to plague and trying to figure
out is there a gene that you could knock
in that maybe has gone silent over the
years in the black-footed ferret or was
never there could you engineer in that
Gene and
um and and that is a you know something
that we are thinking about
um in different ways but to answer your
question about artificial I think it's
important to think about the role of
synthetic biology because
um you know creating novel organisms has
happened and will continue to happen
our feeling about novel organisms is
that there's plenty of existing
organisms to work with we don't have to
really create new ones we're trying to
help save and protect those that exist
but
um being able to
turn back on genes some people call them
lost alleles that have disappeared over
time I think is a very interesting
potential
Poland
sorry
I agreed to moderate it on the condition
I was still allowed to take notes which
is what I like to do when I listen to
ride
um so here's a question from June uh and
I'm sorry who is it from June
um and I'm going to ask this question
but then I'm going to modify it how
would the common birds nurture the
endangered bird chicks so my build on
this is who here remembers reading the
ugly duckling as a child yeah so here's
this mom sitting on an egg and it
hatches and she goes
I don't recognize that I remember the
bird's surprised
well it's interesting or is it all in
incubators so
it's mostly an incubators we haven't
succeeded with it with birds so I don't
have personal experience but I can tell
you that the domestic ferrets
absolutely nurtured the wild
black-footed ferrets as if their own
and uh and and blackfooted ferrets I
don't know if I told you they are
serious carnivores
um and you know they've got some of the
longest teeth of any of the mammals
um and those domestic ferrets took them
on like their own so it happens in
nature all the time surrogacy right I
mean I and some bird species make a
business out of that yes they do some of
bad ones so going down that path a
little further
is can the same there there was a
question that Kevin I peeked at it but
he didn't give it to me
um but I remember it was someone asking
could this technology be used to stop
invasives like no yeah could we do
something with the Florida python well
God I really wanted to do something uh
it's a huge challenge reproductively
with the python
um so the technology that exists that's
been worked on with rodents is called
the gene drive and it what a gene Drive
does is it perpetuates very quickly a
particular Gene selection through
reproduction and what when that happens
you could basically create sterility
now everybody is very concerned about a
gene drive for one species for example
getting rid of rodents on an island by
introducing only males right you could
just get that selection through and all
of a sudden you've decreased your
population but what if that rodent
escapes off the island and then affects
the good rodents other places that's the
big fear so scientists are working on
trying to figure out ways to create
um both uh self-limiting Gene drives and
and they have lots of different
approaches to this so that that
unintended consequence doesn't happen
even should and and an engineered Animal
Escape but to me it's one of the most
Humane things we can do because what we
do for these species like killing
thousands of Burmese pythons
every year in Florida
um if we could create sterility and
remove them it would be a much more
Humane thing to do
using rodenticides on islands has had
huge mortality on other species
especially uh Raptors who eat eat those
um you know sick and dying and dead
rodents uh and they ingest the
rodenticide so you know working with
invasive species is huge now where
they're making progress with this
because I need to give you more success
stories
yeah just a little this is a good one oh
sorry it's a good success story so
um
Hawaii had mosquitoes introduced I think
it was in the 50s I I didn't study that
stat but in the 1950s
1850s oh yeah they came in they
definitely came in uh with the Whalers
and they came in in ship ballast and
everything else those mosquitoes should
never be in Hawaii there are five
species of Hawaii in Hawaii some that
carry human pathogens
like chikungunyen yellow fever and all
these other things but there's another
horrific one that carries avian malaria
that's what those honey creepers died of
and it is causing Extinction like
nothing else
the big challenge is as these Island
temperatures rise the birds who used to
seek a refuge at higher altitudes where
the mosquitoes don't go now they can't
go any higher and the mosquitoes are
going as high as they can so there's no
mountain top to escape to
so
um people in Hawaii have known this
problem and they love their Birds
and they've been completely conflicted
about what to do it this is the the
animal human conflict that just keeps
playing out
and
um so the ins so Gene drives were
proposed I was one of the ones who did
workshops in Hawaii and just they just
went you know GMO forget it
um but there is a solution and there are
folks um that came out of uh Google X
Labs that have used what they are
calling an organic substance called
wolbachia that they can engineer into
the mosquitoes that causes infertility
in the mosquito
and also because of uh their incredible
AI expertise they've been able to uh in
grow these mosquitoes in great quantity
because they can use AI to sex select
something that you know we haven't
talked about the role of AI and all this
but it's just going to be really
transformative for things like captive
breeding of small insects and everything
else
and wolbachi is now being set for trials
in certain Islands it's really worked
its way through from I think having the
scariest idea of a gene drive to
something that now is being called
organic being passable but at the end of
the day it is engineered and it it uh it
will not absolutely knock out the
population of mosquitoes it will just
drive them down and they're going to
have to keep reintroducing these
mosquitoes over time yeah some years ago
I was absolutely startled when E.O
Wilson confessed that if all the all the
mosquitoes disappeared from the world he
would not object
is this biological extremism
well
you know they're
look I was a big proponent I did a
workshop and I I called it
um
mosquito-free Hawaii I just I wanted to
get them all well again off Hawaii it
makes sense if they were invasive but
off the entire planet no but you know
um
it's it's complicated yeah
they're you know
many many species of mosquito they're
not all right it is not a charismatic
species
um
you know Kevin's earlier question about
a technology that it can't leave yet
don't look at your watch I'm just I want
to make sure everybody's okay
you guys okay
yeah
I love this audience I'm going to do a
check-in in about 10 minutes with the
audience okay but okay but in the
meantime don't go anywhere
um Kevin asked the question about
technology that's right on the edge of
being useful and
you mentioned stem cells but it seems
like AI
is definitely in that category it is and
I don't know that much about it and I
need to learn more and computer
scientists don't either so I I'm
following your advice Kevin on AI and
links that you've sent me but I asked
the people who are working with us on
this concept of the stem cell Workshop I
said you know what's going to be the
role of AI and immediately I got the one
paper on the role of AI for
self-differentiation it's one of the
hardest things for the scientists to do
with stem cells and they're already on
it with AI I was like what a beautiful
you know integration of technology so I
it's definitely on the program
So Adam has a question with so many
extinctions and populations in Decline
how would you prioritize which species
you focus on
yeah well so as an entrepreneur I'm
purely opportunistic I look for
passionate people
I look for science that's going to be
really applicable that can make a
difference
those are the biggest things that we
look for
um at the end of the day when we put all
the different wild genomes proposals
together we try to look at is there any
Synergy between teams that we could
actually you know somebody's working on
one part of the coral Challenge and
another can we put them together
um we look for things that are outliers
um the project one people one reef and I
have two people from one people one Reef
right here
Nicole Crane and Giacomo who told you
about his genomic sequencing
um you know we look for people that are
really making a difference and that are
bringing us sort of a broader view of
this whole challenge of integrating
technology and I think magul did such a
nice job in that very short video that
he did from a very remote island at I
think some ungodly early hour to help me
with my talk
um you know Wayne that whole challenge
that they have between traditional
knowledge and new Innovative science and
how do they understand more about what's
going on with their their fish their
they depend on
because you know typically
environmentalists come in and they say
oh you just need to create a marine
protected area you know just wall it off
and you can't do that when people are
living on it but can you say well let's
have science help us tell you how
healthy that population is and at what
density it needs to be or that coral
reef what challenge they're having with
with their livelihood so I I look for
people who really are going to apply
apply it to make a difference
makes sense
um you mentioned the the folks at Yap
who are doing this project and I was
really struck by their statement that
we're trying to augment our traditional
knowledge with science and my day job I
teach at Stanford and we've we've had at
uh at the rumsy map Center at Stanford
traditional Marshallese Navigators and
canoe Builders talking about their
traditional knowledge the same sort of
context
and as I was listening to that I thought
well you know maybe we need some of the
reverse
some of the reverse oh yeah where uh
certain folks in the west would be more
open-minded about augmenting their
science with ethnographic wisdom have
you seen instances of it flowing the
other way are the Sciences influenced by
the cultures they interact with well you
know I can't speak for Nicole but I
think that that project in particular is
profound in that it truly is
collaborative they are really learning
from each other and
um
and I I think you know that that is
really my goal not on traditional
knowledge but I gotta say
conservationists are very traditional I
know you're using it in a different way
but it is an old school approach this
you know wall-off
and protect is one school of thought and
they are completely anti-intervention I
mean there were people when the
California condor was going to go
extinct that said let them die with
dignity
right I mean David Brower this dearly
loved person said let them die with they
freaked out when they started using
Condor puppets to feed the Condors they
said that would ruin Condors forever
that they'd just become fast food
condors and they're now 350 Condors
flying in the wild
they started with 22 that they brought
into captivity 22. and
um and now they're releasing them and I
forget the name of the tribe up in
Northern California or Oregon that is
really going to be the the next release
site and they just feel like you know
part of their their history is now back
I believe that's the Europe it is the
Europe yeah and the Europe by the way if
for us folks in California the yurok are
doing some amazing things
um not just with Condors but with uh
getting rid of dams and it's it's really
super vibrant culture I love hearing
that
um
but now you know Condor is an example of
you know that John Muir everything who's
hitched everything else stuff the
problem with the Contours as they come
back that the four Spanish contact
the big source of their food was whales
washing up on beaches and elephant seals
on beaches now admitted we've got plenty
of elephant seals yeah and admittedly
the uh the the shipping industry seems
to be doing a good job at causing whales
in one beaches but I mean
do you take that into account as you
decide you prioritize which species to
work with yeah that that goes back to a
question that somebody else raised that
I didn't fully answer when we say what
kind of projects I I sort of talked
about the people but we do think about
the species
um and whether or not they have an
ecosystem that can actually support them
and I gotta say that Joshua Tree was one
that I I knew all the problems with you
know what would you call motorbikes and
a lot of the challenges of tourism in
that area and I thought oh good luck
Joshua Tree
um but it was a compelling enough
project and important enough and
important enough for us to do but
um yeah we absolutely look at the right
habitat and we would not want to bring
back either from the brink of Extinction
or from Extinction the species that that
are not going to have a place on this
planet because at the end of the day it
it's not about showing off and doing a
one-off the black-footed ferret is not
about Elizabeth Ann that whole project
is about restoration and we're going to
have many elizabethans if we're lucky
and we're in the process of cloning the
other cell line which is a male which
will be really incredible if we succeed
so I have two last questions yeah so
we'll start wrapping up here and this
one question this is in part coming from
Kevin I wasn't going to mention it but
uh so the question is from uh what was
your first project at revive and restore
and what was the pace of introducing new
projects to the ecosystems of ideas
under which Kevin wrote
I love the mammoth
the mammoth the elephant in the room
[Laughter]
so
um
when Stewart and I started talking about
de-extinction the first person that we
went to even before we used that term
was George Church
um at Harvard and I'd already worked
with George on personalized medicine and
with the Human Genome Project and or his
personal Genome Project and George was
really keen on the Willy numbness and we
bought into it fully because we really
believed that he and others wanted to
bring the woolly mammoth back to help
with ecological restoration and I still
believe that that is a possibility we
never liked none of us like the hype
that it was going to solve climate
change because it was never going to
solve climate change if it has a place
in the environment it could augment and
complement all the other things we have
to do to stop climate change
um but that project which we worked on
with George for
um close to seven years I guess total uh
we funded a small amount of dollars into
his lab and we definitely had staff
members putting time into that
um but at the end of the day it's a very
expensive project and we got an
opportunity
um to there was a a private investor who
came in who said you know I could put
this project on steroids and I want to
funnel that money straight through
Harvard and I want to buy the IP and
that company is called colossal and they
took over the project I guess close to
two years ago now
and
you know I'm a little bit sad about it
because I love being part of that
project and really you know we've
continued to work with George church and
um obviously and we are as Gods stewards
film you could see the passion and
interest in working with Sergey zimov
and pleistocene park you know they're
amazing scientists doing really
important work but
um I don't mind
uh you know not having to answer about
the ethics of of bringing back a woolly
mammoth I got tired of that question
yeah well you know it's it's and I have
one last question but you know it
reminds you the chicken egg argument
that we now have established to the
question of what comes first the mammoth
or the mammoth meatball that in fact
someone just made a mammoth meatball me
personally having once helped excavate
uh pygmy mammoths uh fossils out on the
channel lines I would love a pygmy
Mammoth you know it's sort of the size
of a small anyway okay last question
Jennifer tongue where are you where's
Jennifer
in the dark okay or up there oh good
right there okay all right Jennifer's
question how can I get involved with
cell culture projects as a scientist
with a lot of unconventional cell
culture slash isolation experience
Abalone Tuma tuna salmon
Etc
I don't know exactly how to answer that
but I'm Ryan at reviverestore.org
[Applause]
good
and on that note let's all give Ryan a
hand thank you
thank you
thank you Paul
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]